il y a un type qui habite le quartier
qui m'a dit que j'aurais dû me fasse
sponsoriser par une société d'ascenseur
et que il était sûr que ça aurait marché
j'ai pas pensé enfin là je suis
complètement en amateur
[Musique]
il fait chaud et il est température qui
monte ça donne envie à un certain
Monsieur Beauvais jardinier de son état
de monter des escaliers mais oui en 72
heures il a monté et descendu plus de
1000 fois les 222 marches du sacré-cœur
au total 252 761 marches un exploit qui
Figuera bien sûr au livre des records
habitués des marathons et des courses
d'endurance monsieur Bouvet ne compte
pas en rester là en septembre il
s'attaquera à un tour de France en
courant 6000 km à pied
cet homme ne monte pas à visiter le
sacré-cœur cet homme ne se promène pas
durant 9 jours il va gravir près de 5000
fois les 225 marches de cet escalier de
Montmartre total un million de marches
le comble pour ce marcheur invétéré il
est doté d'une démarche
moi c'est les escaliers c'est la course
à pied
il marche il marche beaucoup
mais il n'est pas cinéphile
et est-ce que votre film préféré c'est
les 39 marches
qui m'a dit que j'aurais dû me fasse
sponsoriser par une société d'ascenseur
et que il était sûr que ça aurait marché
j'ai pas pensé enfin là je suis
complètement en amateur dans 10 jours
après avoir gravi l'équivalent de 25
fois l'Everest peut-être ira-t-il se
mettre les pieds sous la table dans ce
restaurant
il y a bien des moyens de monter
jusqu'au sacré-cœur le funiculaire
simple et rapide le vélo moins pratique
ou tout simplement l'escalier les
escaliers de la Butte Montmartre
justement René Bouvet les aime tellement
qu'il les montent et les descend toute
la journée presque sans s'arrêter
pourquoi parce qu'il veut battre un
record du monde et franchir 2 millions
de marches en un mois je suis très
concentré sur l'effort quand je descends
quand je monte sur la marche et je ne
pense à rien il y a un effort je suis
dans l'effort et je fais le vide
comme tout sportif de haut niveau René
Beauvais est entouré d'une équipe
d'assistance techniques des bénévoles
qui se relaient pour tenir une
comptabilité scrupuleuse de son exploit
et le ravitailler en vol a raison d'un
repas toutes les deux heures un arrêt au
stand et hop c'est déjà reparti pour
encore un tour
une équipe d'assistance mais aussi des
supporters pour eux l'essentiel n'est
pas de participer mais de soutenir
[Musique]
ah quand le funiculaire ou ça me
brancherait bien demi-heure c'est cool
dans le même sans bouger avoir à manger
c'est cool en fait pour René Bouvet
monter des escaliers toute la journée
est une façon de trouver la sérénité de
larmes par l'élévation de l'esprit et
c'est vrai qu'à ce rythme là
l'équivalent de 5000 étages par jour le
ciel se rapproche très vite
[Musique]
2 millions de marches montées plus 2
millions de marches descendues égales 4
millions de marches nouveau record du
monde de 7 curieuse spécialité le
champion s'appelle vimmotion Beauvais 49
ans il en aura fini ce soir après 57
jours d'efforts sur les marches de la
Butte Montmartre cet homme est-il
totalement sain d'esprit
je suis pas plus fou que les gens qui
font la course de Figaro
ou que pedibouche
l'Atlantique donc je suis un quelqu'un
qui fait des records et qui aime
l'escalier notamment celui-là qui est
exprime une force
physique je dirais donc c'est une
rencontre entre deux forces
vimotion Beauvais est un disciple du
maître à penser indien srichinmoy qui
place la clé de la sagesse dans le
dépassement de soi ce dépassement là
aura fait perdre 16 kg à vimmotion
Beauvais ce sera son 7e record sur les
marches de Montmartre en attendant son
prochain défi sans doute une traversée
de l'Atlantique
[Musique]